circo mundial es un programa sobre
el sol que usa las artes del
circo a través de intervenciones como
manera de educar a los jóvenes
situación vulnerable
paquete de progreso de artes circenses
prácticas artísticas como la música
el teatro la danza pero también la
trapecio malabares acrobacias
ines tintas que un conjunto de practicas
que ayudan a los jóvenes a desarrollarse
habilidades sociales como
10 carpetas para las travesías
apoyo de ayuda mutua sino también a
tomar riesgos
probar cosas para averiguar
cosas para crear vínculos entre
ahora los participantes y crear
vínculos entre la comunidad
el cirque du soleil ha elegido la causa
jóvenes, que nos pareció bastante
un hecho natural desde el circo del sol
fue fundada por un grupo de jóvenes que
encontrado en las aguas del siglo a
espacio de expresión un espacio de
creatividad
una manera de hacer sus diferencias
su marginalidad una fuerza y
florecer
el programa surf y mundo existe
para muchos
circo mundial es un programa sobre
el sol que usa las artes del
circo a través de intervenciones como
manera de educar a los jóvenes
situación vulnerable
pack de grupos de artes circenses
el artista practica y le gusta la música
teatro danza pero también trapecio
malabares acrobacias calamares
que conjunto de practicas que
ayudar a los jóvenes a desarrollarse
habilidades sociales como
despachado para la acción acro ayuda mutua
el apoyo sino también para tomar
riesgos probado cosas para averiguar
cosas para crear vínculos entre
ahora los participantes y crear
vínculos entre la comunidad
el cirque du soleil ha elegido la causa
los jóvenes nos parecían bastante
natural desde que el sol fue fundado
por un grupo ii
que encontró en las artes circenses un
espacio de expresión un espacio de
creatividad
una manera de hacer sus diferencias
de su marginalidad una falsa y de
florecer
el programa mundial de circo existe
desde hace muchos años
y queremos compartir esta experiencia
allí con todas las organizaciones que
trabajar con gente joven
dificultad
por eso nuestras herramientas son gratuitas
de uso te invitamos a
utilizar para adaptarlos para transformarlos
para compartirlos
en lo que seis más para crear
Fuerte trampolín de ute para lograr el
cuadrícula
ocho ex trabajadores de sochaux y circo
artistas sí pero sobre todo sigo
todo brasileño esta iguana google widget
bob aprendes a concentrarte habrá un
entrenamiento base de respaldo para hard 1 to
bob pickup live va a entrar
juego uno que hacemos de pura apuesta de la antigua
armonía chad y n36 chad
por lo tanto, cualquier comunicado de prensa
valonia
el cirque du soleil cree en las artes para
círculo mundial cambio social
es un proyecto que llevó a cabo artes y
creatividad para trabajar
jóvenes en dificultad
[Música]